Narrator: This car crash during
the "Shang-Chi" bus fight
was real and filmed on
location in San Francisco.
But the shots we see right after
were shot thousands of miles away
on a soundstage in Australia.
Perfectly matching the stunts, camerawork,
and visual effects in these shots
was just one of the challenges
in creating this
six-and-a-half-minute fight sequence
that took an entire year to make.
So how did "Shang-Chi and
the Legend of the Ten Rings"
pull off its unforgettable bus fight?
Since the release of "Shang-Chi,"
many have called this bus sequence
the best fight scene in
Marvel movie history.
When putting this sequence together,
director Destin Daniel Cretton focused
on constantly raising the stakes.
That can be seen in everything
from the number of
fighters to the set itself.
Andy Cheng: This is
one of the big sequence
I think I ever worked.
With all the element.
Narrator: That's Andy Cheng,
the film's fight coordinator.
Doing kung fu on a moving surface
added a brand-new layer of difficulty
for the experienced stuntman.
To handle all the moving pieces,
the action and the bus' path
were mapped out thoroughly.
How thoroughly?
Well, even this shot of a passenger
filming the fight on his phone
was there since the storyboard phase.
And the previsualized CGI
shots of the bus' wild ride
provided an accurate roadmap
for the stunt team to plan around,
as you can see here.
To really nail down the moves,
the team had to rehearse on the actual bus
used in the scene, instead
of just at the gym.
Cheng was inspired by a lesson
he learned while working with Jackie Chan.
Cheng: We always have to have the sequence
or storytelling with locations.
Sometimes you read the script, you know,
"Oh, this is happening in this thing,"
but you just do it at the gym.
You start pretending,
"Oh, this is a table."
For me, I feel when you go
to the location and see it,
that's how you create things,
because those thing is
really not pretending.
Narrator: Practicing on the actual bus
also allowed them to solve
some practical challenges
they might not have caught earlier.
For example, Florian Munteanu,
who played Razor Fist,
was so tall that he kept hitting his head
on the bus ceiling during rehearsals.
We had to constantly remind him,
"Hey, watch out! Duck down!"
Narrator: These rehearsals also identified
where they should add rubber padding
to the poles, bus floors, and chairs,
which was useful here,
when this fighter collapses into a seat.
And to make a flip like this
happen on a set this crammed,
the team reconfigured the buses
so they could be taken apart.
For example, all the chairs could be moved
to make room for stuntpeople
and camera operators,
and the windows could be removed
to allow a camera to pass through.
The crew also built a
sliding camera track up here,
freeing up room for hand-to-hand combat,
like in this shot, which
starts out behind Razor Fist
and then ends up in front of him.
After rehearsing, the
next step was figuring out
how to execute a fight
scene on a moving set.
Cheng wouldn't have been
able to safely achieve
these stunts on location,
as the bus speeds downhill
with many difficult twists and turns.
So the crew constructed two bus rigs
to simulate the movement.
The first was built 3 feet off the ground
on a rig capable of moving and shaking,
but it was used for more
standard driving shots
with a somewhat stable
surface for fighting.
You only can make the
bus, like, this much,
the tipping maybe by 10
degrees. That's maximum.
Narrator: The second bus was built
on a 15-foot-high gimbal
capable of tilting at a 45-degree angle.
It was ideal for when the
bus careens down steep hills.
And because it was so high up,
there was plenty of room for the back
to move and swing rapidly.
They can be like this,
and then they can rotate,
and then they have more room.
They can be like this.
Narrator: The bus could
even drive on an angle,
like when it's wedged
between a garbage truck
and a row of cars.
And the previs helped the
stunt and special effects teams
adjust the gimbal's exact
movements before filming.
But the most difficult
shots to get were the ones
when Shang-Chi jumps out of the bus.
They had to make it look like
the character was really
hitting the ground
and trying to regain his balance.
So the stunt team set up a treadmill
next to one of the buses.
Cheng: So, in real life,
if the bus is moving,
it foot touch the floor, there would be,
like, constantly sliding,
because he cannot stand on it
because the floor is moving.
Narrator: The illusion wouldn't work
unless the bus kept moving,
which is why you can see it
bouncing up and down off the ground.
This particular moment was so complicated
that the stunt required both bus rigs.
For the first part, the
team filmed a stunt double
as Shang-Chi dodging Razor Fist
and then jumping onto the roof.
This was done on the higher gimbal,
as it required a sharper turn.
Cheng: So that one, we can
tip the bus, like 45 degree
and then, boom! Flip it up,
and he's on the ceiling.
Narrator: The second part was filmed
as one continuous take
that ends in a close-up,
meaning Simu Liu had to
do the stunt himself.
So they used the lower bus rig.
Liu first positioned himself here.
Less rumbling meant he could
run the length of the bus,
slide, and grab the front mirror
as this Technocrane followed along.
Cheng estimates that they
nailed it after 10 takes.
But not everything went according
to the previsualized plan.
Like this shot, for example.
In final rehearsals, Cretton
didn't find it believable
that Shang-Chi could pin
Razor Fist against the wall
simply by putting his
foot up against this pole.
Cheng: He's such a big guy.
I cannot really buy how
he can have enough power
to trap him like this.
Narrator: So Cheng reshaped the scenery,
switching out the pole for these chairs.
That way, Shang-Chi could place one foot
against that seat and then jump up
and land on Razor Fist's back.
Cheng: He put one foot on the ceiling,
and then against him using gravity,
and all his weight on top.
Narrator: But for Cheng,
this might've been the
toughest shot to get,
when Shang-Chi kicks Razor Fist
into the breakaway back of the bus
before diving into the front section.
To get this shot, Liu had to jump 20 feet
while doing a 180-degree
turn onto the ground.
And so they wouldn't have
to actually destroy the bus,
it was all shot in front of a blue screen.
An even faster slider track
gave the camera enough
speed to capture the jump
while moving back to
give Liu plenty of room
to land on his mark, right
in front of the lens.
And then the camera moves superfast.
It's almost like chasing gravity.
Narrator: It took roughly 15 takes,
an entire day's worth of work,
for about four seconds of footage.
Now, none of these action
highlights would work
if the soundstage shots
and the real shots on
location didn't match up.
The two units shot simultaneously,
but there were lots of
adjustments the crew made
to make it feel more
organic, like lighting.
Cinematographer Bill Pope built
light grids around each bus.
The lights were rigged to imitate
light captured on
location in San Francisco
and cast accurate shadows.
Notice the bus' accordion flaps moving
as if they were being hit by real wind?
That's because these crew members
manually moved the flaps around.
In the end, it's hard to tell
that this car crash was
filmed in San Francisco
and the shot of two
vehicles wedged together
was shot on a soundstage
thousands of miles away.
Cheng: Over this,
Man: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
and now you come back. "Ahh!"